I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I was
it was already begun a concert blood
first it will be ready they know we're
coming
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 breakdown video today I'm going to
take a closer look at the preview teaser
for episode 3 to try and get a better
idea of what may take place in the next
episode shall we begin
first let's start off with the scene on
the beach where we see a group of people
arriving on a small boat as they are
being greeted by a larger group of
people that are waiting for their
arrival on the beach it appears to me
that those are some Dothraki men
standing on the beach and I think this
will be Jon Snow and Davos landing on
Dragonstone to meet with Daenerys
Targaryen in episode 2 Melisandre told
Daenerys to summon Jon Snow to
Dragonstone so Daenerys could meet Jon
Snow for herself and hear the stories
about the things that Jon has seen with
his own eyes to prove to Daenerys that
the long night is upon us because
Melisandre knows that Daenerys is going
to be needed and it might take the help
of Jon Snow to convince her about the
army of the Dead that is coming Tyrion
sent John a raven telling him to come
the Dragonstone Jon also received a
raven from Samwell Tarly telling him
that Dragonstone has a mountain of
dragonglass
Jon now knows that he must go down there
and mine some of this dragon glass and
hopefully while he is there he can also
form an alliance with Daenerys Targaryen
not only because she has a very large
army but she also has three
fire-breathing dragons that are going to
be the ultimate white killers Jon Snow
left in episode 2 and now he has already
arrived on the beach in the very next
episode this will be one of the most
important meetings of jon snow's life
with the army of the Dead coming
Daenerys has everything that Jon needs
right now on Dragonstone her three
dragons can kill all the whites and
there is enough dragon glass there to
make everyone a weapon so they can
increase their chances of killing every
single weight walker - but it's not
going to be easy
the next shot we see a group of people
walking up towards the castle on
Dragonstone if you look closely at the
group of people you can see Davos John
and missandei as they are being escorted
by some Dothraki men I think terian is
going to most likely be right here -
because he walks into the throne room
with John when he meets the mares which
is the next clip we see Tyrion missandei
Davos and Jon Snow walk into the room as
Daenerys is awaiting for them on her
floor
and this should be a pretty epic moment
John Snow and Daenerys Targaryen finally
meeting for the first time there are
actually family members and they don't
even know it yet
Jon Snow's father is Rhaegar Targaryen
which is Daenerys Targaryen s brother
but although Jon Snow might be king in
the north Daenerys is going to expect
him and ask him to bend a knee to her
because Daenerys sees herself as the
rightful ruler of the Seven Kingdoms but
I do not think John is going to bend a
knee though John has already shown that
he is not going to rule the same way
it's always been done when John Snow is
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
he told tormund he wouldn't ask the
wildlings to bend the knee to him John
also had a lot of respect for Mance
Rayder - and he wasn't bending his knee
for anyone and I think John might do the
same I think torment may have been right
when he told John he had spent too much
time with the free folk John has always
done things his way even if it can get
him killed but on the other hand I could
also see John doing whatever it takes to
get the help that he needs if it takes
bending the knee for him to get the
support of Daenerys and her forces I
think he would do it because it would
benefit everyone in the long run John is
going to tell Daenerys about the army of
the Dead and he's going to ask her for
her help but does anyone think Daenerys
is going to set aside her plans right
now for John she probably won't she's
already in the middle of a war by the
time John gets there Daenerys will
probably have already received word
about what happened to her allies Euron
Greyjoy just wiped out you're a Greyjoy
fleet and he killed several of the sand
snakes in the process then he took your
olaria and tyene prisoner which he is
going to take the King's Landing at
Circe's gift I think the nurse is going
to want to act fast after she hears
about this
she already has men in place to go to
Casterly Rock and take over the
Lannisters ancestral home with all of
this going on Daenerys is going to tell
John that she isn't going to be able to
help him right now but there is another
scene in this teaser that may be showing
Daenerys contemplating her decision in
this clip Daenerys is over looking to
see most likely thinking about
everything that is going on right now
her forces are split up and some of our
biggest alliances were just killed and
taken prisoner now the king in the north
is here and he is saying he needs every
soldier and dragon
have up north to fight the army of the
Dead that she wasn't even expecting to
fight she is probably going to be torn
trying to decide what she needs to do
next while she's out here John snows
probably going to come up to her to
speak with her privately one-on-one when
they show the next angle of Daenerys you
can see someone at the top of the steps
coming down which I think is Jon Snow
which I did point out in my Comic Con
trailer breakdown but another clip from
this teaser shows her turning her head
to look at someone coming up next to her
out here Jon and Daenerys will talk and
probably have a better understanding of
each other and come closer to respecting
each other and their planes even more
next we see songs in the godswood at
Winterfell walking away from the
weirwood tree I think brain stark will
arrive in this episode and out here bran
will reveal a massive revelation to
sanso about the truth we saw bran
sitting in a wheelchair out here in the
trailer and as Sons is walking away if
you look right over her shoulder it does
appear that someone is behind her
sitting in a chair as well most likely
it's going to be her brother bran stark
and with all the tension that's going on
in the north right now whatever brain
tell songs out here could make things
explode bran could potentially tell
songs about Littlefinger and how he
betrayed their father which might be the
tipping point for Sansa in Seal
Littlefinger's fate brain could also
tell songs about the truth of Jon Snow's
parentage now it's still kind of
undetermined whether brand knows who
John's father is or not but he
definitely knows that John is not Ned's
son and this information could shake up
the entire north Sansa has already been
having some issues with John so there's
no telling what she might do if she
finds out John isn't Ned's son he would
still be family with Stark blood but
since her and John aren't close as some
of the other star children she might not
care and I'm really anxious to see this
scene to see how it's going to play out
then we see euron greyjoy as he arrives
in King's Landing being greeted by a
welcoming crowd of cheers as he struts
around on his horse with his brand-new
prisoners and gifts for the Queen Cersei
Lannister you're on just kicked the [ __ ]
out of Yara grey join her fleet along
with the sand snakes who are travelling
with her I was telling you all for
months that Euron was going to be a
savage this season and I'm so happy they
actually delivered on that his
introduction to the show was pretty damn
bad but they have done a great job with
his character now
and I got to give props to the actor who
really turned up the intensity during
the battle on the sea he looked like a
[ __ ] maniac and I loved it but as
you're on his gallivanting through the
streets if you pause the video at the
right moment you can see he has you're a
Greyjoy right behind him on a leash that
he has in his hand and the remaining
sand snakes probably aren't too far
behind when Euron arrives in the Great
Hall he takes a bow to Cersei as he
presents his gift which we all know
Cersei is going to love she hates the
sand snakes olaria especially ever since
she poisoned her daughter back in season
five I don't think Cersei is going to
show any kind of mercy on Ilario and I
wouldn't be surprised if she makes her
watch as she murders her daughter tyene
right in front of her Cersei will
probably have the mountain finish them
off but I don't think it's going to be
quick he might take them into a room
just like what's up to Anela he raped
and murdered over and Martell sister and
he killed her children
then he squashed Oberyn Martell's head
like a grape and now he's about to
finish off the rest of them next we see
Cersei and his teaser talking to someone
in private and she says the war has
already begun and she drawn the first
blood and I can't really figure out who
she is talking to right here when I look
at the color of the sleeve the person is
wearing it doesn't look like a burner
Jaime's type of clothes I was thinking
it could be a Lauria or tyene sand but
I'm not 100% sure about that either but
I do think this is someone new that she
hasn't spoken to yet this season Tyrion
Lannister speaks in this teaser - and he
says Cersei will be ready but we aren't
exactly sure who he's talking to either
at first I thought he might be talking
to Jon Snow but I think he could be
talking to Theon Greyjoy as well Theon
could ask about getting his sister back
or Daenerys may be furious herself and
want to get into the city to get them
back when she finds out
but Tyrion knows Cersei would be ready
for that or Tyrion could be talking a
grey worm Indian solid before they leave
for Casterly Rock letting them know that
Cersei would have people ready for an
attack there but they could go through
the drain system to sneak in and catch
them by surprise which is something we
see in this preview also grey worm puts
on his helmet as they get close to
Casterly Rock and this will most likely
be right before he turns around and
gives his men the nod to stay alert and
be ready themselves they will exit the
boats and go through the drainage
system they will take out a few guards
inside which we see one of them laying
on the ground here already as they storm
the castle and take it over this will
probably be a quick battle that won't
take up too much time in the show
because then this same episode Jaime is
going to be striking Highgarden there is
a quick clip of Jaime walking into a
courtyard and I think this is at
Highgarden which is the seat of Lady
Olenna and house Tyrell Jaime and Bronn
plus the Lannister forces will sack
Highgarden which will cut off the food
supply to Dragonstone which should be a
big blow to Daenerys because she has a
lot of mouths to feed in Dragonstone
doesn't produce any food on its own not
only will this cut off supplies to the
mares but this will also feed Jaime's
army and horses to which he desperately
said he needed in the very first episode
when Jaime takes over Highgarden this is
going to kill two birds with one stone
but as this is going on the Lannisters
are going to be losing Casterly Rock at
the same time it appears this next
episode is going to be jam-packed with
tons of action meetings and even some
reunions this should be a really good
episode that might take the pace up
another level from the last episode and
I'm really looking forward to seeing how
the power is about to shift in Westeros
after this episode is over
the Lannisters might lose Casterly Rock
but Daenerys is about to lose her third
major ally in her camp Yara olaria and
maybe even Lady Olenna Tyrell is going
to be removed from the equation after
this episode is all said and done while
the Lannisters gained the full support
of euron greyjoy and randyll Tarly the
tide is beginning to shift and we aren't
even halfway through the season yet and
Qyburn has yet to put his new weapon in
action Daenerys might need to help from
the north sooner than she thinks but
comment down below and let me know how
you think all these things are going to
play out in the next episode thanks for
stopping by and I'll see you down in the
comment section bye